il aura été l'un des plus puissants
criminelle du québec
maurice boucher est né en 1953 à
causapscal dans le bas saint laurent il
grandit dans le quartier hochelaga
maisonneuve à montréal une vie de petits
truands grand consommateur de drogue
vers la fin des années 80 il fonde son
propre chapitre des hells angels
les nomades un des groupes les plus
craints même homme a de l'ambition
c'est l'époque de la guerre des motards
le but de cette guerre là c'était
vraiment le contrôle total au québec et
en ontario où une partie de l'ontario un
contrôle total sur le trafic vient des
bombes sont les motards s'entretuent
allègrement faisant au passage
d'innocentés victimes comme le jeune
daniel desrochers 11 ans en 97 coup sur
coup deux gardiens de prison sont
assassinés l'un par stéphane godasse
gagner qui devient délateurs et accuse
maurice boucher d'avoir commandé les
meurtres le chef des hells angels est
alors arrêté mais acquitté entouré de sa
garde ils narguent les policiers
par son tempérament frondeur se
présentant sans gêne en public mais la
fin est proche c'est sûr qu'il va y
avoir un appel la procureure france
charbonneau se bat pour que bush et
subissent un second procès
le vent tourne pour les nz l'escouade
carcajou multiplient les assauts contre
les motards l'opération printemps 2001
décapite le chapitre nomads
maurice boucher subi un second procès
cette fois ci en 2002 et les condamnés à
perpétuité
même à l'intérieur des murs il continue
à sévir en 2015 il est condamné pour
avoir comploté le meurtre du caïd
raynald desjardins son influence au sein
du crime organisé s'évanouit mais son
rêve d'expansion dr angels persiste on
peut dès aujourd'hui sans se tromper que
la majorité des territoires au québec et
suite à la fin de la gamme des moteurs
en ontario il ya eu dès la création de
chartes et rachid et en ontario
je sens une certaine façon oui leur
réussit mise à l'écart des autres
détenus à l'intérieur de
sainte-anne-des-plaines maurice mom
boucher a succombé à un cancer de la
gorge dans l'ombre la plus totale il s'y
marie josée pas capcom ou radio canada
montréal